Jeremy Corbyn has always attracted
support from the far left due to the
causes he supported over the years no to
war on Iraq but can party to the left of
labour have any impact at a time new
alliances are being formed and you kit
and green votes are being squeezed the
Labour leader has addressed huge crowds
in this campaign activists like Claire
help to turn them out although she's a
Socialist Party member he was previously
stood against labour as soon as we heard
that there was going to be corbin rally
in leeds
as we put it up on our official Facebook
page and what that then started was a
kind of chain reaction where our members
would start to post the information on
their own Facebook profiles but also
where we would use whatsapp and text
trees that kind of thing to get the word
out the biggest far-left political party
fielded 135 candidates at the last
election this year they're fielding none
hoping to swing the result in a number
of marginal seats there were nine seats
which the Tories won in 2015 which gave
them their parliamentary majority where
the total majority across those nine
seats was 1600 votes one in Derbyshire
was only forty votes so dozens of votes
can make a difference no nine hundreds
or thousands here at Labour HQ of course
they're focused on far bigger margins
than that
but these are separate political parties
trying to shore up support where they
can for Jeremy Corbyn and hoping they'll
be granted some say in Labour's future
labour everywhere there is support for
Jeremy Corbyn even further to the left
the British Communist Party will stand
no candidates in this election for the
first time since 1920 they're a very
small party but jeremy corbyn's election
advisor Andrew Murray was a member until
five months ago they have high hopes our
members and our local organisations and
we are organised in just about every
part of Britain many of them have made
approaches to their local labour party
organisations in quite a few cases those
have been welcomed and we've assisted in
a practical way
labor sources say these groups are very
marginal and that Jeremy Corbyn has half
a million enthusiastic labour members
behind him they say his cheerleaders
from the past won't get their foot in
the door tomorrow in Sky News
[Applause]